they've protested for months against
Hong Kong's government today they came
to storm it trying for hours to batter
their way in then a moment that could
prove pivotal in these protests for the
first time they breached the Citadel and
swept through the corridors of power in
Hong Kong
in the chamber of Hong Kong's Parliament
the seat of government they demanded the
resignation of officials dog the walls
with slogans against Chinese tyranny and
draped the old flag of British colonial
Hong Kong five demands which is tsurara
the extradition bill and they also want
the those processors who were arrested
earlier to be released unconditionally
the day had begun peacefully but with
another massive show of people power to
millions say organizes a quarter of Hong
Kong's entire population and the sense
among some of them this movement is only
just getting started
I think this is going to go on for a
long time if the government does not
withdraw the bill completely and does
not express or have any actual plan to
rebuild the communication between the
people and this is a woman people say is
not listening to them chief executive
Carrie Lam was toasting the anniversary
of Hong Kong's handover to China and
trying again to sound conceal it truth
can you fathom you see the incident that
happened in recent months has led to
controversies and disputes between the
public and the government this is made
me fully realize that I as a politician
have to remind myself all the time of
the need to grasp public sentiments
accurately but outside the numbers were
growing with protesters determined their
voices are heard once more government
not trying to avoid our voice again
because you know we are the future
Hong Kong citizens and we have to fight
for our future
by nightfall outside Parliament a tense
standoff
police tried to smoke protesters out
with tear gas before moving in
determined to crush the biggest
challenge yet to their control charging
with body armor and battles against
unarmed protesters the occupation of
Hong Kong's Parliament was temporary but
potentially game-changing the power of
these images will injure as China's
government in Beijing and its Hong Kong
surrogate plot their next move
Dominic Waghorn Sky News